e-mail que le biotope le plus proche de
l'homme justement grammy grâce aura
justement peut soigner des enfants ont
passionné des maladies orphelines qu'on
n'a pas d'argent pour un ravin un homme
mais dit ça à mon homme qui est en train
de mourir enfin c'est pas possible de
dire non mais j jacques berdou des
berges et des rats non mais je le ferai
avec plaisir j'avais chez moi je n'ai
pas chasser quoi c'est pas vrai bah oui
bien sûr y goûte toriola tous des rats
c'est pour ça tout
ça at elle dit chez toi tu es trop tu
vas bien leur petit voisin jean nuit moi
j'ai eu
d'oracle a que comme ça qu'ils disent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien c'était
du côté de
miniatures et votre épaule avec clinton
compte que c'est pas des mini un faux
méchant train de faire un documentaire
fait jamais ça
jamais jamais ça jamais une mini en fou
alors qu'on a une grosse info
jean temps de faire un documentaire sur
les rats est ce que vous savez pourquoi
il ya un clapet sur les toilettes parce
que très rarement sûrement par les
canalisations et leurs petites pattes 10
dont 6,6 à temps
[Applaudissements]
je suis
sur l'échec
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
habib originaire de
segi lingerie pour 400 pour coach n
8 i'm ok
pour quelle chaîne cette dure quatre
chaînes pour des thèmes si je pense à
tout jamais c'est vite j'ai appris à
tout jamais cessé vite je me tais à tous
a lancé ces menaces et les toits gilles
quelques jours les rassure et une paire
de gifles droit te dire bref alors à
quoi bon alors sur les rails
il a raison ça peut aller vous savez ce
qu'ils font en prison il a raison parce
que oui mais non il n'ya pas de classe b
to b une bouteille voilà il va être une
bouteille et c'est vrai que franchement
et ils sont pas ça peut pas nous mordre
et
non mais les mecs tu es comme ça tu es
tranquillement des comas centre admire
oui l'eau arrive et il te choque les
couilles
et la glande sébacée
[Applaudissements]
juste derrière
tu te regarder comment
[Rires]
ça cool
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]